and one of those neighbors was officer
Clements remember him well friends walk
Clemens broke ground by becoming one of
the first African Americans with a
recurring role on the children's TV
series he says it was a transformational
experience following a turbulent
childhood in our series note to self
Clemens writes words of encouragement to
his younger self My dear little
buttercup yes that's what we all used to
call you sweet little buttercup one day
if you stay focused
folks will know who you are and they
won't tease you about being sweet but
for a while they will tease you about
that and singing and wanting to play the
piano and dancing and playing with jacks
you're gonna have many experiences as a
little black boy growing up particularly
because you like being with the girls
and so you find yourself constantly
feeling like an outsider for whatever
reason you don't want to do what the
other boys are doing you will discover
that you are who you are and it cannot
be preyed away I know that you've only
seen two or three shows on television
that features someone that looks like
you but believe it or not you will make
history it's a beautiful day in this
neighborhood
beautiful thing for a neighbor you must
get to Pittsburgh because something is
going to happen to you huh that you've
been longing for all your life yes who's
here
Oh officer Clemens how are you and when
you meet this man something about him
it's going to draw you in a way nobody
else ever drew you and called you and
he's going to love your singing he's
going to encourage you would you sing
something for us sure why don't I sing
the song that I was singing to myself as
I was coming over here oh I'd like to
hear that
[Music]
he'll change your name and call you
officer Clemens hi officer Clemens
command mine won't you sit down
it's an anoint you in your role as a
helper on his television program hello
miss paulifficate in bubble and the
temperatures perfection Charlie to the
neighborhood of make-believe with
stopping down mr. Rogers neighborhood
growing up you have a slightly different
view of what police officers represent
in your community but your heart will
open when Freddie explains the positive
influence that you can have for young
children swing low
[Music]
one day you will go on to college and
continue to sing so that you can travel
all around the world and touch the lives
of many people when you give yourself
buttercups folks will have a taste of
that sweet life and begin to believe in
themselves against they'll know that
love does exist
there's the singing
and that there's much more than all of
us can do when we choose to do it
together
[Music]
I'm so proud of you Francois oh thank
you Fred
Francois can sing and he can write
believe in Buttercup I love that story
and the fact that he was known as
buttercup that's right we've published a
book based on our note to self series
note to self inspiring words from
inspiring people is on sale now it's
published by Simon & Schuster a division
of CBS